[Musique]
je m'adresse aux travailleuses et aux
travailleurs comme l'a fait dans le
passé à l'aide d'aiguillés lorsqu'elle a
représenté lutte ouvrière aux
précédentes élections présidentielles je
m'adresse à tous les exploités ouvriers
employés techniciens qui font marcher
toute l'économie mais qui n'ont en
contrepartie qu un salaire dérisoire
alors que tant de riches parasites gros
actionnaires spéculateurs amassent des
fortunes sans rien apporter à la
collectivité
je m'adresse à tous ceux dont l'activité
est utile à la société personnel des
hôpitaux et de l'enseignement chercheurs
mais aussi petits paysans commerçants et
artisans qui n'exploite que même on nous
parle de liberté égalité fraternité
mais dans une société où presque tout se
vend et s'achète pour être réellement
libre il faut être riche et qu'elle est
l'égalité et la justice
quand les uns passent leur vie au
travail pour survivre alors que ceux qui
n'ont rien fait d'autre qu apporter des
capitaux en poche les milliards qu'ils
ont prélevé sur l'exploitation et quelle
est la place de la fraternité dans ce
système capitaliste où seule compte la
rentabilité et le profit la crise
actuelle aggrave les inégalités elle
aggrave l'exploitation pendant que le
chômage explose et sur ces cinq
dernières années et que les petits
boulots occasionnels et mal payés se
sont multipliées les dividendes des
actionnaires ont été préservés ils ont
été garantis et mieux même pour les
actionnaires du cac 40
ils ont augmenté de 31 pour cent pendant
que les salaires stagnent et et que le
pouvoir d'achat dégringoler la
rémunération des grands patrons a
augmenté de 34%
ce qui est révoltant c'est par exemple
dans certaines villes du nord pas de
calais on a justement la misère qui
côtoie la richesse c'est des villes
comme croix comme rouve et on assez
ancien industriel du textile se sont
recyclés qui ont placé leur argent à la
bourse qui ont mis de l'argent dans ces
empires comme l' empire mulliez et d'un
côté donc c'est des milliardaires qui
savent plus quoi faire sur de leur
argent qui vit sur un tas d'or et de
l'autre côté des quartiers on voit le
chômage qui augmente qui est maintenant
à 20% 30% la classe capitaliste profite
de son pouvoir absolu sur l'économie
pour faire payer la crise par les
classes populaires afin de sauvegarder
ses propres revenus et ses profits dans
usine où je travaille les conséquences
du chômage ces corps on et 3000 cdi et
il ya 1400 intérimaires et les pas trop
où ils en profitent qui à chômage massif
ça se traduit dans l' usine par des
conditions de travail qui se dégradent
le patron est libre et que si t'es pas
content il y en a des centaines de morts
et puis les conditions de travail se
dégradent on travaille plus 1 alors que
d'autres s'enfoncent dans le chômage
le patronat se sert du chômage comme
d'une arme de guerre contre les
travailleurs pour exercer un chantage
permanent et faire accepter le blocage
des salaires la flexibilité la précarité
l'augmentation des cadences le premier
des combats à mener et contre le chômage
contre les licenciements
les travailleurs n'ont pas accepté de
payer pour les ratés d'une économie dont
ils n'ont jamais tiré profit dans cette
campagne je veux dire aux travailleurs
que si individuellement chacun d'entre
nous est désarmé devant la puissance de
l'argent
collectivement nous pouvons réagir et
changer notre sort tout ce qui va lever
le drapeau des luttes pourront le dire
en votant pour ma candidature alors le
22 avril
votez et faites voter pour nathalie
arthaud
[Musique]